foreign
[Music]
I have to say as a side note um for
white guys you guys have my body like my
shape my personality and it's not a good
thing for you it's really not a good
thing for you but when I looked at you
because you look at Andrew Schultz and
you look at Stefano they're like human
they're like yeah yeah and they do they
look not mythological they look like
they can stick their penises in anything
you know I mean you guys look like in
cells like you guys look we do beat more
penises out yeah
ones in here my mother was a Minotaur
like I don't know anyone in La that even
has your Vibe sure maybe like there's
some homeless comedians
if you go to open my late at night I
love how he said he's gonna be nice this
episode
because I feel the same sure yeah right
I go I think that you guys are white
versions of me and that's why I'm
blessed to be here that's what I'm
saying yeah thank you thank you so much
wonderful wonderful compliment because
because you guys I know you guys get you
have a girlfriend I have a wife you have
a wife you have a girlfriend girlfriend
right and that to me is like
mind-boggling it really is to me it's
like oh my God it does too yeah yeah it
works it's working I know I mean that
means you have the humor goes a long way
because those guys the Stefano and
Schultz and these guys right they have
their looks to get them by right anybody
can get broads when you look good right
do it looking like us but right with us
dude it's like we're like Miracles like
we're like killing the game right and we
we're also Paving the way for other
uglies yeah right so we we're storming
the beaches here yeah yeah and now let
me say something right if you lost
weight yeah you could have like a Gary
gallman Vibe right but you
no shot
89. let's go back to the mall station
why not yeah let's get back to the Fun
Spot
don't say that but please let's
your nose is out of control
your nose dude it's like I can't even
deal with it because even when I was
performing and I saw him up there
we you know literally I was eight
minutes in you've just been I know but I
was like on stage and my side that was
my tip that was the tip of your nose
right here my side angle is not good
but nose is like yours are all the rage
with with Jews we got Nikki Glazier we
got Ali Wong we got these very
attractive very likable women you know
what can I say something I find you more
attractive than those two ladies well
well well what a nice thing to say yeah
do you have sort of a interesting look
[Laughter]
Pacific
and guess who likes it turnips and
turnips only yeah that's the only thing
that likes you look like a hot mechanic
[Music]
I'm trying to be honest can I just be
real please I recently watched that
movie Alien the first one okay look at
the thing that came out of the stomach
I'm gonna punch you no no no no no no
but you're like you know if Sigourney
Weaver had died from the alien like with
the acid
he's hot well
I'm an alien being covered in acid this
is the same not your face just to see
your body or whatever my body whatever
you don't know what's under here you
said that day I said something about
people and you're like I never want to
see your tits no like I wasn't planning
on showing you I don't want to see her
tits
not not that you're still going to
remember that you would work on that
spaceship right because you know those
kind of because they're trying to
because when you look at like a movie
like that like alien or like if you
there was um something like that where
it's like they're trying to uh portray
Working Class People but it still has to
be Hollywood so they have to be kind you
know be attractive still you know okay
but still people relatable that's what
you are like a relatable mechanic in a
movie burned with acid no no I I raised
the acid part right yeah okay okay yeah
okay so that's okay that's good I'll
take the hot mechanic yeah so I I I I
you know in fact if you Nikki cleacer
and Ellie Wong were on an island and I
could choose one to penetrate
which one should I eat
that's the thing like when your body is
weird it really is like it's it's like a
weird body thanks in a good way oh it's
not good it's not wait what's weird yeah
it's like you and JF Harris have the
same body oh God
I love him anyway no I like JF too I
don't have the same body as him it's the
same it's like what's weird about my
shoulders like it's skinny up in the
shoulder area yeah and it's like it's
like kind of like a um squash
I know it sucks
[Laughter]
I hate it so much
yeah but look at mine I saw Santino last
night and he was making fun of my body
yeah yeah dude let me say this and I
honestly believe this and I'll say this
out loud right
your stand up and how fun you are
is levels above Andrew Santino
on time to camera don't drag me into
this I'm not I really believe that I
think Andrew's one of them oh yeah he's
great but him and I we worked well
together and I love them as a person
right but just be truthful I think
you're funnier and a better comic all
right I'll take a better joke writer
you've been eating a lot huh
your face as actually your face has
gotten a little chunkier I like it
I do I do I like your face because
you're being serious no honestly because
do you really think I look a little bit
a little chunkier I like it that way
that's cuter wait really do I seriously
yeah you really do your face I [__]
shaved I should look I should look no no
when I saw your face earlier what the
[__] is going on with his face
maybe it's the corona scare or whatever
I've been eating a lot yeah I mean you
guys so much it's it's really it's nice
it's filling out it's filling out yeah
because before you're doing like this
Hollywood like I'm gonna make it kind of
a Vibe and now you've covered your face
has given up
it's cool did you shave your head for a
part huh a roll
no I'm bald no no but going I know but
did you because you still had some stuff
residue of hair residents yeah yeah you
had residue you know I mean he's gonna
die a Chernobyl thing that you were
doing but
yeah but you didn't you just understand
it
yeah it's one of those things are we
going right now no we don't there's no
there's no rules but okay I'm just
asking a question okay right I'm gonna
answer I I understand that but why are
you your head looks like you know um
Darth Vader when he took his [__]
helmet off
when he was just all [__] up yeah yeah
what
is that is that the that's fine you're
Bill Burr but
I'm trying to answer your question yeah
go ahead I just process you coming out
of the gate [__] on me
um yeah you know when you start to lose
your hair you got three options
you can yeah
and there's subsets to all of them all
right okay you can do the Rogaine the
hair plugs right system uh [__] all
of that piece
Propecia a [__] uh they glue some
[__] on your head right it takes some
some of your pube hair and you get an
afro yeah or you can uh just sort of let
it happen which what you were doing
which I was like that's the dope way to
do it oh I'm glad I'm glad I had your
approval or you can just say [__] it
yeah and do what I did so I just said
[__] it okay and and I do I love how you
came at me aggressive and now you're
going you got your little panda
what
you [__] up before that you know that
right hey uh I lost his mic because you
keep [__] moving around because you
won't sit still for five [__] seconds
he even told me I'm professional like a
[__] [__] you
um
no hey now be nice I love them you know
it's a joke comedy bro
yeah I did that's gonna happen three
more times 100 like nine minutes no
doubt in my mind that it's gonna happen
again okay I'll sit still like this good
luck can you hear me now dude well he's
not back there yet
go back to your station dude
testing testing
what's your name I want to call you Dude
because I'm gonna call you Dude
Tom cassetta Tom cassetta can I let me
tell you something Bobby the look in his
eye it's Bobby's underwear inside out he
[__] hates you guys it's his second
day on it probably oh did you hate me
dude look at his face always stop stop
oh [__] look at his [__] face he's
livid you know what you want you when he
wants to say he wants to say Charlie
yeah like we're attacking him
why are you saying we yeah you're
attacking him and you're Charlie you're
Korean try that again try it again
we'll get cleaning get a clean tank
again
I'm glad I had that phone we're coming
back dude what was up with his face
Santino do you know something about his
face what the [__] was that what was on
his face what do you think he was
thinking dude yeah he thought uh he he
is Mitch McConnell and I'm his wife
that's right
yeah yeah
let's try that one what Rodney King
let's go back to that yeah
we're used to [__] take my style yeah
do you remember that I would get a
[__] armband you would get an armband
yeah but you never called poser
what anywhere I went people like pulls
her under their breath oh really yeah
and I had to be like correct oh really I
don't know I had pretty good style back
then good great style that's so great a
toy machine yeah oh I'm so good the cool
thing about skate art is you don't have
to skate you can just buy the shirts
that's true I realized that long ago
yeah yeah you can [__] what are you
wearing under that what what style are
you wearing underneath this is like uh I
have a jersey underneath but yeah yeah
what kind what I don't know Jersey
that's posing too you think this is yeah
you [__]
you know I hate to like oh yeah yeah
whose jersey is that
I've never seen Bobby wearing basketball
jersey yeah I love jerseys man I love
this team and I love this guy
how's it doing this here pretty
I don't know he's not on the team
anymore you know what I mean yeah but
yeah yeah anyway
um
what a [__] car what me what do you
mean I love this guy yeah I love the
team I'm La for for Life bro for live
dog yeah yeah so anyway
um
we're having a good time right we're
having a really good time we're gonna
poop in your car yeah you do get
defensive around Akash yeah have you
noticed that can I tell you why though
why why because that's not who he is oh
[__] who am I Bobby oh you want to know
who you are yes go where's my phone at
yeah
right there okay yeah I'll tell you who
you are he planned he planned this last
night
at dinner he goes
yeah I said Bobby Lee because you didn't
have my number right yeah you open up
with love you but love you buddy love
you buddy is that new yeah but that's
not the Bible give me you're not giving
me a love your body and then I'm gonna
read all of them you two you're super
funny and you're nicer no that was me
saying that for real man
hahaha
[Laughter]
yeah yeah are you circumcised no yes he
is yes I am yes I don't even know what
that means did you once a week I texted
him once a week because he's gotten
sober I want to check on him never
responded this guy wow
you're a nice guy
you're empathetic right yeah yeah you'll
get high if you eat that that's a
mushroom I should even paint your house
it feels like I added this wall here and
I you know you know but even when I go
walk into the living room it's like a
different vibe
is it a good vibe you seem like it's not
no it's uh
I always had a perception of your house
in my mind
I hated it well oh God like it's it's
like uh it's something that Jim Henson
would live in or whatever
you know I mean the well you create like
I mean felt you know puppets why do you
think that is why do you think because
of the because of the no it's the decor
like it's a museum the wood it just
feels like some old-timey 1970s guy but
then when I walked in at this time it
was like
um it felt
fun like uh Moriarty's house
you know fun well Moriarty's house
wouldn't be fun it would be
um he's up to no good but it just has
this like 19
1800s 1800s now we're back
let's go further back yeah 1800s guy who
like is trying to foil you know Sherlock
Holmes
so I don't know whether you like it the
house or not I love Paulie
but I've seen you've seen them up close
it's a good guy it's not yeah yeah it's
like small Polly smells pretty good
we're talking about him like I love
[__] homeless like he's not homeless
he's got millions no yeah of course yeah
and he's done very much he's a Pioneer
great man
yeah but it's you look at his face and
it's like you know what it looks like is
remember when Gollum was a human right
and then Smeagol right and then he
became Garland but Paulie's in the mid
stage remember when he bit the fish
he bit the fish in like the third one of
the transformation
and then they they show him in the cave
and it does like a long dissolve and he
turns old right he looks mid
metamorphosis goleming there's like five
phases of Jewish man I don't think I
slept enough for this
I'm like one beat two yeah because I'm
feeling the feeling I'll tell you what's
going on with me I'm feeling the feeling
the feeling of of just
don't just tell us sing it you're good
with this
what what
happened you know yeah yeah yeah oh I
don't know like that so I got a feeling
it's an angry feeling
a killer Jewish guy
smash his face against the pavement
the [__] it's a rug store your daddy's
Rockstar sucks
like something like that you sounded so
good I felt pretty good it sounded
really good yeah yeah let me say
something okay yeah I love you thanks
for coming
is that the show
good night is that the shortest post
this is a clip or the episode that
doesn't exist
[Music]